[Musique]
excusez moi j'étais en train d'écouter
alain baraton le jardinier en chef du
domaine de trianon 30 armes ont été
recensées par les équipes du château
dans un circuit d'arbres admirable
allons les découvrir
[Musique]
sinon bonjour mais l'ami vous êtes les
gestionnaires du patrimoine arboré du
domaine déjà pourquoi avoir choisi de
mettre en avant ces arbres on a voulu
mettre en avant les arbres admirable du
château de versailles
parce que pour nous c'est pas nous
jardinier c'est un patrimoine très
important parfois un peu méconnue alors
par exemple celui ci qui est derrière
nous ce très vieux chêne qui est le plus
vieux vieilles arbres du domaine il a
trois cent soixante-cinq ans a survécu à
la tempête de 99 et à bien d'autres il a
survécu sécheresse il a survécu à la
révolution et c'est pour ça qu'on
voulait absolument qu'ils fassent partie
de notre de notre parcours il est très
certainement arriver là tout seul mais
il est fort à parier que louis xiv et
andré le nôtre sont passés sous les
frondaisons assez régulièrement on a vu
un on fait un petit oui on va aller en
voir d'autres
on a encore quelques autres du côté du
petit trianon par exemple
trente cas ont été identifiés par les
équipes du château en fonction de leur
âge ou de leur rapport à l'histoire
les jardiniers se sont inspirés du label
arbre remarquable
ça c'est un des 37 un sophora du japon
c'est bien ça tout à fait c'est un
sophora du japon l'île à presque 200 ans
et il est contemporain de marie
antoinette en fait celui là on est sûr
que c'est elle même la jeune reine qui a
demandé à ce qu'on plante un arbre ici à
cet endroit là pour qu'elle puisse le
voir depuis les fenêtres du petit
trianon et elle voulait également un
arbre asiatique un arbre exotique et on
est certain que marie-antoinette passer
le voir très souvent aimé beaucoup cet
arbre est donc c'est pour ça qu'il est
venu s'insérer dans la collection des
arbres admirable merci sylvain parole
des arbres il y en a partout et je vous
propose maintenant qu'on aille à
l'orangerie
à l'orangerie cinq spécimens ont été
identifiés alors voilà un grenadier qui
est moi je les aime beaucoup parce que
j'aime l'aspect torturé comme ça du
tronc ce côté un peu baroque associé à
la régularité
là on est vraiment dans le jardin on va
dire régulier cette ce jardin maîtrisé
par cette nature maîtrisée par l'homme
tous deux profitaient de ces arbres
admirable il vous faut pas grand-chose
il vous faut votre téléphone
des écouteurs télécharger l'application
qui ne vous reste plus qu'à en profiter
moi il me reste encore une vingtaine je
vais y aller
[Musique]